um let's listen to some of these hinge
audios i was going to delete hinge but
then they came out with the audio
feature
i hate these new text-to-speech videos
at driving with my knees
i was feeling super stressed so i went
to the doctor and she gave me
some pills for anxiety so i tried them
out and i ended up adopting
six pet rats fried chicken
daniel
like the name daniel
to use it in a sentence
hey that cool guy daniel over there
having a bath after a long day is
literally heaven yeah hinge has this
feature where you can reply to like a
prompt about yourself with a voice
recording so these dudes are like
answering questions like how do you say
your name and whatever and
the lack of charisma is
it's mind-blowing
very evident yeah the funniest one was
the version where the dude just read the
prompt out loud
and like didn't respond to it
that [ __ ] killed me
like he thought that the others like say
this phrase yeah is there a girl can you
voice yeah it's like you know it's like
what's your favorite drink what's your
favorite drink
i don't know the [ __ ] point of that i
bet you can't yeah that's the one
i bet you can't
i bet you can't
the random fact i love is sloth sleep 20
hours a day
cool yeah i don't know
you're probably gonna have to figure
that out i don't know i don't know yeah
i don't know
georgia
give me travel chips for what georgia
georgia
sick tip dude all of georgia oh this is
important uh i order
for the table
miller lights and fireball shots if you
don't like it i'm sorry dude these are
[ __ ] hilarious what a what a
man
what a weird thing to keep up
i order fireball
and bud light if you don't like it sorry
sorry is this new hinge update
brag about you to my friends if we can
go out drinking most nights
and you can actually keep up with me
because i've been drinking since i was
like 10 11. wtf is this
that dude that was wasted
recording that yeah no
either that or it's like he just just
woke up
or it's like right before he's gone he
just woke up in the middle of a bender
yeah he just [ __ ]
if we can go out drinking most nights of
the week
james
james
james cause i've been drinking since i
was like 10 11. james what are you
saying are you okay
is [ __ ] up man that [ __ ] aged him 40
years beyond his age
that dude was like 22 sounded like a war
vet
what girl is gonna listen to that what
woman is gonna be like yeah that guy
makes me feel safe
i just like responded
oh i definitely want to hang out since
he was 10. that's a good sign
means he can handle his liquor this is
my dude this is my guy
damn i thought he was hubby material
yeah
yeah then drinking some sauce 10 or 11.
i really thought it was english that's
how drunk he was for the first half of
it
yeah i'ma update my tinder audio
that [ __ ] that blacked out look in
someone's eyes was like
that dude in the party
that's like in the corner you know
i don't know that reference dude you're
13.
i just meant like you know those tick
tocks of dudes that are like yeah i'm
gonna talk to so many hoes tonight and
the hoes come over and they're just like
in the thing just switching apps like in
the corner switching apps he's doing
that but he like switches by a hinge and
he's like oh [ __ ]
a tunnel
uh
[Music]
he's doing it in the corner of another
room because he doesn't want anyone to
catch him
and we got a dream
james there's girls here man shut the
[ __ ] up i have to start over oh if we go
out
that [ __ ] is so funny bro
is there another one please
i love these so much like his replies
are like people do you think it's just
women being like hey i'm not interested
but i just want to know like are you
okay okay yeah
my my brother's been in aaa for ten
years yeah he's done a lot for him yeah
please get a sponsor
i could be i'm not interested but i
could be your surprise i could be your
sponsor i want to keep you on the
straight path
all right what is this loaded hinge for
the new update and wow
wow i got four nipples
yeah
daddy no
it's just it's just jacob i'm sorry
about that i got i got excited i just
tried
i'm just
this is unreal
daddy
[Laughter]
i get excited
record nailed it
boop that's definitely going to get him
time to turn around brother go around
always looking at me i'm down looking
down i just want to say now i ain't
turning around that drama little mama i
want to take a minute and i know i'm
coming up to a little bit concealer and
i keep up here how the boy want to eat
and i'm trying to tell that i can't beat
treat like clientele cause they sure she
delicious
but i ain't promised you boys and if you
were suspicious all that [ __ ] is
fictitious i blow kisses
at the end he was killing it up until
that point
damn i want to get on there just to do
that i bet you can't and just do rap god
that reminds me oh
damn this is this is like mean but
whatever elena
elena and i went by the way i haven't
been
to rodeo drive as an adult like in a
long ass time and i went there over the
weekend and that that place is also
a gta server oh yeah
it's just a lot of strange characters
there
and so whatever
we're going to the store alina's buying
some [ __ ]
and the cashier i feel mean doing this
but whatever she's ringing her out
having a conversation
she says something in the middle she
laughs
but i felt so bad because her laugh just
it was just like a
it was like
you know i just i fell for her what what
story did she work at no no that's fine
where was it it's fine
and she kept going i just it made me
feel for people with ugly laughs
you know they can't help it yeah
she just has to go around in life with
them
and she's like yeah totally that one's
pretty bad actually now i'm thinking
about my own laugh
yeah
yeah
it's not to say i have a good life
either but
hers is just like yeah
mm-hmm was like holy [ __ ]
super mario
like
that same
it's one of those laughs where there's
like a weird silence afterwards yeah
every single time yeah
she's like what's wrong is this that
funny it's like
it's like there's air pressure being
released and she can't stop it yeah
you